[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEROME DOCHEZ: Hello.
Welcome.
I'm Jerome Dochez.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
CHRIS WARRINGTON:
I'm Chris Warrington.
I'm also a software engineer.
IZABELA ORLOWSKA: And I'm Iza.
LEO SEI: Hi guys.
I'm Leo.
I'm a product manager.
So we're here to talk
about the Gradle plugin.
But, first, I want to
talk about build speed.
You've already heard
from Karen this morning,
who recently looked
at our data and had
some interesting findings that
I wanted to share with you
today in all transparency.
The metrics that
you're going to see
comes from developers
who opt in into sharing
their data with us.
So if that's your case,
thank you very much.
So, first, we
looked at build time
change a little
bit across a couple
build times before and right
after an Android Gradle plugin
upgrade.
And so what you see here is
the immediate improvement
in speed and percent.
And you can see that, outside
of a minor regression in 3.1.2,
we've been pretty
consistent at 7% or 8%
and even 20% with 3.2.0.
So we thought, OK, if everyone
upgrades to the latest
3.2 or the latest release,
build speed should be getting
faster and faster, right?
Well, not exactly.
Turns out that, when we looked
at build speed over time,
it is getting slower and slower.
And I don't want to call this
the build speed conundrum,
but it got us a
little bit puzzled.
How is it possible
that, on one end,
we keep improving with every
release, and on the other end,
we keep seeing build speed
gets slower and slower?
After some exploration,
we realized
that the build ecosystem
is very complex.
And I'm a new guy at
Android, so I can tell you
it is very complex for me.
And it's rapidly evolving
with so many things
that can impact your build.
For example, your
apps are growing.
You're adding more code.
That's great.
It can slow down your
build a little bit,
but that's not the lion's share.
Turns out that 96% of you use
some form of Gradle plugin
outside of the
Android Gradle plugin,
whether it's another Google
plugin or third party
plugin or even
something that you
wrote for your own app
or your own company.
And when we took a look
at some of those plugins,
they were not all
super optimized.
There's also a lot of
annotation processors out there,
and they sometimes
lack incrementality.
So when you do a tiny change,
it has to recompile everything,
and your build speed goes away.
Some new languages-- like Java
8, for example, or Kotlin--
can have some impact
on your speed.
With Java 8, we mitigated
some of the impact
by merging the dexing
and the desugaring
together in one step with the 8
and working a lot with JetBrain
to improve the Kotlin compiler
and annotation processor.
There's also some
resource scaling issues
if you have a lot of modules.
Some of our existing
resource pipeline
is not necessarily optimized.
So you can see
that that's a lot.
And when you add
all of this, it can
have a pretty significant
impact on your build.
And to top it off, a
recent survey that we did
showed that 60% of
developers either do not
analyze build speed at
all or do not know how to.
So there's definitely an
awareness problem, as well,
around what can cause
delay to your build.
All right.
So what can we do?
Well, first, I want
to recognize that some
of what I just
mentioned comes directly
from us, Google at large.
And we're really serious
about improving this.
We're taking steps internally
to improve existing features, as
well as the new one.
But as I mentioned, there's
also an awareness problem
and tooling issue.
And we want to launch new
features and new attribution
features that can help
you better understand
what's going on with
your build and what
is really impacting your build.
And we'll cover this
in a little bit.
We're also really doubling
down on performance features,
working together with
Gradle, and there's
a lot of new features that I'll
let Jerome, Chris, and Izabela
share with you.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Thank you.
So let's get started.
What did we add in the
latest 3.2 release?
The first thing I
want to talk about
is incrementality in
annotation processor
that Leo, you did before.
As you probably know,
Java C and even Kotlin C
has been incremental
for quite some time.
However, if you have
annotation processors,
all of this incrementality
goes out of the door,
and so it's a big problem.
And so it has enormous
performance ramifications,
because when we look at
our internal dashboards,
we can see that the
JVM bytecode production
tasks are the most consuming
task of all build time.
So, basically, being
non-incremental
is a huge problem.
So Gradle, with [? Groupon ?]
and with Google,
has come up with INCAP, which
is aimed at making annotation
processors incremental.
Now, there's really
two levels of support
that we are aiming for.
The first one is called
aggregating, which basically
means that, if you change
a class, which is annotated
with an annotation
of interest, we
will have to recompile all the
classes which are annotated
with the same annotations.
So it's not exactly
incremental, but it's better
than recompiling everything.
The other one, which
is called isolating,
which is much better,
much more fine grained,
will allow you to recompile
only what has changed.
So there is this different
levels of support.
What is important to
realize for some of you
is that, if you have annotation
processors yourself that you
developed in-house, it
would be your responsibility
to make those annotation
processors INCAP compliant.
We are working hard
internally to make
the most popular annotation
processors INCAP compliant,
so we're going to
do Dagger, and we're
going to do data binding
and all this kind of stuff.
But if you have your
own, you're going
to have to work on it yourself.
And if you don't, we also plan
to make it very, very clear
that, if we have to
revert our compilation
to not be incremental,
we're going
to make it very clear which
annotation processors are
forcing us to not
be incremental,
so if you're providing
those, expect
to have some bad publicity
coming from us saying, yep,
we are running a non-incremental
because of those annotation
processes.
The second thing I want to
talk about is App Bundle.
So you must have
heard about it by now.
In the past, when people
wanted to reduce the APK size,
they had to do multi
APK, which resulted
in a lot of manual steps
related to deployments.
Was very complicated.
So now what you can do is
basically create this App
Bundle, which is a glorified
zip file with a universal APK
in a specific format, which
cannot be immediately installed
on a device but can be used by
the Play Store to precreate all
these different APKs for all
the different devices that
you're targeting.
So you have got, fast delivery,
all these nice features
without having to
do it yourself.
Now, one of the thing
you need to understand
as a developer using the
Android Gradle plugin
is that there are
things which have
changed because of that, right?
For instance, you
know, you can define--
if you use modularity, and
you have feature modules,
for instance, you
can define a number
of things inside of
those feature modules,
yet the base module is
the one that will actually
be providing some information,
even for the feature modules.
So, for instance, the
application ID, the version
code, soon the sign in
information, all of those
comes from the base ID.
In theory, we would want to
reduce the DSL [INAUDIBLE] type
so that you could only
provide on the [INAUDIBLE]
Gradle of each of
these feature modules
the exact information that
we know we would be using,
but we don't have time.
So it's the same DSL
everywhere, and you
have to be aware that some of it
will be ignored in the feature
modules.
Also, for instance, the
mapping file for a Bundle file
will also be for
the base module.
Now, when you add modularity
inside your application,
it's relatively easier to build
[? level. ?] All you have to do
is to use the right plugin,
as I described in this slide.
At the base module, you
have the base functionality,
and then you apply the
application plugin,
which you have used for years.
In a feature module, you can
apply the dynamic feature.
Now, we have to declare
what special dependency
from the base module to all
of the different features,
and I will explain you
later why this is necessary,
but it is something
that you need
to understand is
that, obviously, you
have a dependency from the
feature module to the base,
but you also need
to make a dependency
from the base to the features.
As an example here, we've got
the [INAUDIBLE] shrinking flow,
and I'm going to show how
this changes when you start
introducing feature
modules and modularity
inside your application.
So, here, you've got
a simple example.
You've got a base module.
You've got three feature
modules, module A,
module B, module C. So far,
nothing's too specific.
Of course, each of these feature
modules depend on the base.
Now, by adding this
DSL declaration,
we are declaring that the
dependency, or the fact
that those features--
those module A, B and
C-- are feature modules.
OK?
So far, simple, but
you can see that now we
have this dependency
going both ways.
So when we go through the build
flow, the first thing that we
do, obviously, is that we build
normally all the Java source
files.
We compile all the Java
source files into classes.jar.
That's normal.
That's the normal
process that we
go through when we build each
of these different modules.
But the thing that really
starts to differ when you're
dealing with feature modules
is that we are publishing back
all of these JAR files
back to the main module.
And that's absolutely
necessary, because when
we do the code
shrinking, you need
to have a global view
of the application.
You can't do a shrinking
just on the feature module,
because you will not know how
and what the use of the base
class is, for instance.
So once you have those
published to the base,
you can feed it to the
shrinker and the splitter,
and, eventually, it's going to
create equivalent dex files.
As you can guess, there is
more or less a one to one
mapping between the original JAR
file containing the class files
and the dex files
containing the dexes,
but it's not exactly
a one to one.
So, for instance,
let's say that you
had classes that were
in your base module
that you thought would be
shared by different features
but only end up being
used by, say, Module B,
then it's perfectly
legal for the splitter
to decide that it wants to move
those classes into the dexB.jar
instead of keeping them
inside the main dex.jar
of the main module.
Otherwise, you can more
or less imagine that there
is a one to one mapping.
So once this is done,
you've got all these dex
files, which are still
residing in the base module.
Now they're going to flow back
into the originating module,
dynamic feature module.
And we do that so
that you can have
as much parallelism
in your build.
So as you can see,
at the beginning,
we had the
compilation happening.
In each of the same modules, it
was potentially parallelized--
depends on the machine
you have, but if you
have a powerful machine, all
of those would run in parallel.
Then we moved
everything to the base.
Then it becomes
kind of a bottleneck
for the build system, because it
has to wait for all the modules
to be ready to be able
to do the shrinking.
Well, once this is done, we
can move back the processing
to each of the
[? same ?] modules.
So you can see that adding
modularity to your application
may be a good software
practice, but it's also
a good practice in terms of
the build, because we're going
to get much faster over time.
We move as much stuff as we
can toward the lifts of all
of these modules, and we can
run all of those in parallel
as much as possible.
Once this is done in parallel--
once this is pushed back
to whichever feature
module, we can then
resume the normal
processing, and, eventually,
we will create all the
necessary APKs or all
the necessary artifacts to be
able to create the App Bundle.
All right?
So all of those,
again, is in parallel.
Now, obviously, the shrinker--
the fact it's a little bit
of a bottleneck, like
I explained earlier,
is usually not a
problem, because--
not a problem for
debug build, at least,
because, usually, people do not
use shrinker-- code shrinking
during the debug builds.
It's only done for
the release builds.
But we really try to limit these
bottlenecks as much as we can,
and Chris will
explain also how we
have enhanced a lot
the resource processing
with this type of improvements.
Another thing that we
added in 3.2 was D8.
So D8 is the new JVM byte
codes to dex file translator.
We will eventually remove the
old one, which was called DX.
If you still are
using DX, you really
need to stop
[INAUDIBLE],, because we
are going to remove it.
And once we removed
it, you will not
be able to upgrade any longer.
So if you are using DX because
you have issues with D8,
you must file a bug
immediately and follow through
to figure out what is wrong,
if it's with your build
or if it's with D8 itself.
Otherwise, you're going
to get stuck in the past.
R8 is going to
follow more or less
the same path,
meaning, like, it's
available right now to try.
We are very happy with the
results we are getting so far,
so it's very stable.
You should definitely try it.
Eventually, it
will become stable,
and you can guess what's going
to happen to the old code
shrinker to plug out.
Eventually, we will also
remove it and completely
replace it with R8.
If you want more details,
there is a session tomorrow
that will give you a lot more
technical details about how
these two libraries
are implemented.
OK.
Let's talk a little bit
about what's next in 3.3.
So the first thing I want
to talk about is lazy tasks.
So Gradle has introduced
the concept of lazy task,
and the lazy task is-- you
should really understand it
as a task that will only get
initialized and configured
if it is on the
execution task graph.
So that means, for instance, if
you got-- let's keep it simple.
You've got two variants, the
debug variant, the release
variant.
And if you're coding
assemble debug,
there's no need to initialize
or to configure any of the tasks
for later to the
release variant.
And so what we used
to do, unfortunately--
so this was done before in
this particular example, where
we used to create all
the tasks-- we still
have to do that-- but
at the creation time,
we were also configuring them.
So we were ending up
configuring all the tasks
for debug variants and all the
tasks for release variants,
even though only the
debug were eventually
going to be executed.
With lazy task,
Gradle is giving us
the tool to basically delay
all of this initialization
until it knows that those
tasks will be executed.
Now, when I say executed,
it's not entirely true,
because what it really
means is that it's
going to be up to
date checked, meaning
it's going to look if
the task needs to be run
or not by running its
up to date checks.
But potentially,
at least, the task
is on the execution
task graph and may be
executed if it's out of date.
So how do you do lazy tasks?
It's basically very
similar to the old style.
Instead of doing create,
you call register.
But you can see that now the
configuration code, which
is in blue here,
where you initialize
the input for the
value, will only
be called if the task is on
the execution task graph.
Now, we used to really
pay a lot of attention
for all of our
configuration tasks
to make this configuration
block as lean as possible,
because they were
always executed,
so if you were to do,
you know, Gradle tasks,
it would always execute
all of this configuration.
So we tried to keep
it as lean as possible
with no access to disk,
no access to network,
for instance.
Now it's probably
a little bit more
OK to do more work in
those configurations
if you really have to, but you
have to remember two things.
First, if you do real
work, it will still
impact your build time, because
the configuration time is still
a mono threaded event
in Gradle, meaning
all of the configuration will
happen one after the other.
So the more you do, the
longer it will take.
And you already know
today that, you know,
configuration time
happens all the time.
It's very annoying.
We are really trying to
reduce it to the bare minimum,
but any time is really annoying.
The second thing is to
not look up tasks anymore.
So when you have, like, build
a Gradle customization--
a lot of people are, like,
doing project, get task by name,
or kind of stuff like that--
this will actually
look up the task
and initialize it
and configure it.
And if you do that,
it will not only
do that for the
task itself, but all
of its transitive
dependencies, as well,
all the tasks its users
and all the output
and all this kind of stuff.
So you basically
have a good chance
of initializing
your entire world.
Instead of doing that,
you should get a provider
and get a lazy
object of the task
itself and use that to
register your dependency.
Now, what you can also do
if you want to have access
to the output of a task is
use that provider and map
the output using this type
of API to get a provider,
so it's basically a
promise on the folder
or a promise out
of a regular file
that a task that may
execute will give you later.
You can see how the
level of interactions
you are getting here.
But, eventually,
it will give you
the idea that you can get
an object which represents
the output of a task,
and that object does not
initialize the task itself.
Getting this provider does
not initialize the task,
does not force it to run,
and it's really lazy.
And it contains also the
dependency information,
which means you don't
have to register yourself
as a dependent of the task,
producing this output folder.
Just holding the object
itself, the provider,
will allow you to not
only get the object,
but also register
your dependency
on whatever is producing it.
Eventually, you can do a
get, and that will give you
the actual task and
the actual object
that you can use to
configure your own task.
So, here, when Bar is
getting configured,
Food gets configured,
and, eventually,
all the dependency of
Food will get configured
and so on and so forth.
So you can see how
lazy this is becoming.
We are retrofitting
all of our tasks
to become [INAUDIBLE]
providers and stuff like that.
So if you use
customization a lot,
you really need to look
into these two APIs in 3.3.
And now Chris will talk about
some of the other improvements
we've made.
CHRIS WARRINGTON: Yes.
Another optimisation to the
build process coming up in 3.3
is Light R classes.
Previously, the
Android Gradle plugin
would generate an R.java
for every single dependency
in every subproject
and then compile them
alongside your actual classes.
In Android Gradle
plugin 3.3, it just
generates a JAR containing
the class directly.
Especially for builds with
many library subprojects,
and lots of dependencies, this
avoids a lot of compilation,
a lot of I/O. For some
large multi module builds,
we actually saw double
digit percentage and speed
ups when building from
clean due to this change.
So the R class system
in Android Studio 3.3
has been rewritten to simulate
all of these R classes
in memory rather than
relying on the ones on disk.
Having this, as well as enabling
this optimization of the build,
it actually speeds up
indexing in Android Studio,
as well, even for projects
with all the Gradle plugins.
This does, however, break
some Gradle plugins that
depend on reading
the R file directly,
including [? Butter Knife, ?]
which I'm working on fixing,
and it's implemented
for library use in 3.3,
and we're working
on implementing it
for applications and tests, too.
As Jerome mentioned
earlier, Gradle [INAUDIBLE]
for incremental
annotation processing,
but it does need
support from annotation
processes themselves.
And he said that we're
working to support
the most popular annotation
processes, including
Dagger, room, glide, auto
value, and some others.
We're also working to
re-architect data mining
to allow it to be an
isolated annotation
processor, speeding up your
incremental [INAUDIBLE] even
more.
We also want to help you
understand that build time
impact of annotation processes.
So we want to
report to you, like,
which annotation processes
was time spent in,
and how much did they cost?
On that theme, there
are several other areas
we want to give you better
insight into your builds,
easily and simply.
So if you're using
annotation processes,
it's really critical that
you have that insight,
because they're
often a bottleneck
for incremental builds, for
a lot of builds that we see.
When a Gradle task
causes you trouble,
it's really helpful to know the
Gradle plugin or the scripts
where it was created and
what triggered it to run,
and we're working to make
finding that out more easy.
We also want to help you
find these types of issues,
even if you're not
actively looking for them.
So longer term, we want
Android Studio to flag
if there is an issue
or if something
changed and regressed.
And we'll point you
towards the Gradle
build scan, which is a
powerful tool for getting
a bit of insight into
how your build's working.
OK.
So on from these kind of better
insights to complete rewrites,
Android resource namespacing.
Resource namespacing is
a completely new pipeline
for compiling and linking
Android resources.
So we're actually doing
this for two reasons.
Firstly, speed up the build and
make it easier to understand.
Secondly, we want to better
support dynamic features.
Looking at how things work
now, in the existing resource
pipeline, there are two
namespaces, the Android
platform and everything else.
That means that, if you
have two libraries--
the defining resource of the
same name and the same type--
the resource manager
has to pick one,
and it's not always clear
what the right thing to do is
or even that it's
happening at all.
This actually also makes
splitting your APK up
into several dynamic
features much more difficult.
As each dynamic feature
is shipped separately,
where those resources
come from and where
they go is really important.
With resource
namespacing, each library
is compiled and linked
separately, and then
linked together
into the final APKs.
The R class in applications
would no longer have final IDs.
And then when you're using
resources from both XML
and from Java, you need
to be explicit about where
they came from.
So each resource is only
listed in the archives
from the library
that defined it,
and in XML, you need to use
the namespace of the resource
to refer to it.
This also means the resources
no longer implicitly override
one another just because
they have the same name.
For cases where you needed these
overrides in the application,
we're working a new way
to do that explicitly.
AARs that we generate
from namespace libraries
will be backwards
compatible, so you
can have all the benefits
of namespacing yourself
but not impose it
on your consumers
until they're ready to switch.
OK.
Passing onto Izabela to tell you
a bit more about the details.
IZABELA ORLOWSKA: Thank you.
OK, now that we know what
resource namespacing is, let's
move on to how
to, in the future,
namespace your app or library.
You might find yourself
asking questions like, where's
that resource coming from?
Or, what is the proper syntax?
Or, how do I even
namespace my dependencies?
Well, the answer to
all these questions
is, we'll fix it for you.
So the solution is automatic
namespacing or auto
namespacing, for short.
There are two main parts here.
First is the automatic
rewriting tool
in the IDE, which will help
you migrate your local modules
to be namespaced.
And the second one are
the transforms and tasks
in the Gradle plugin
that will rewrite
your remote dependencies under
the hood, no action required.
Here is an example
dependency graph.
The blue notes are
local modules that
can be rewritten
using the IDE tool.
The three orange notes
are not namespaced,
classic remote libraries that
will be automatically rewritten
by the AGP.
This means all the
resources, classes,
the manifests will be rewritten
to use the full resource
namespace.
And, finally, the
green notes are--
they represent dependencies
that are already namespaced,
so they will not
be modified at all.
Let's see what
types of changes we
can see after this
migration takes place.
In the bytecode or
Kotlin and Java sources,
you can see that,
now, there will
be different R classes present.
If a resource was defined
in a different module
or a remote library, you will
see the package of the R class
will change to
match that package.
In the XML resource references--
like in the values files
or in the manifest--
you will see the
new namespace appear
between the at symbol and
the type of the resource,
similar to the
Android namespace.
And, finally,
another way resources
can be referenced is in
attributes-- for example,
in layouts.
Here, the XML namespace
will be modified
to point to the correct
package, instead of res auto,
and the attribute will use
this new namespace, as well.
And since we're already
on the topic of resources,
let's talk about
resource visibility.
So probably many of you
created an Android library
with a lot of effort into
declaring which resources
are public and then published
this AAR with a public.txt,
only for consumers to ignore it.
This currently is
only a Lint Warning.
This code compiles and
runs fine at runtime,
completely ignoring the intended
visibility of the resource.
I'm sure many of you actually
ignore these warnings, as well.
Great.
So to combat this, we want to
introduce stricter resource
visibility.
So these violations will now
become build errors instead,
so it will catch them
early, and we will introduce
three levels of visibility--
one, public.
This means these
resources will be present
both in the public R
classes of the consumers
and the private R classes
for that local module.
Private resources only
present in private R classes.
And, last, private
XML only resources.
They will be not present
in any R classes at all.
Instead, you can only reference
them from other XML files
within that module.
This will result in
smaller R classes, both
compile and runtime, and also
resource hermetization similar
to the class or method
of hermetization
currently in Java or Kotlin.
So with that, Leo?
LEO SEI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So, as you can see, we're
working on a lot of things,
and many of which we hope
would help with build speed.
Going back to my point
about awareness and tooling,
I want to share
some of the things
that you can do today to
understand your build better
and improve its performances.
The first things is to upgrade.
If you recall my first graph, we
do improve with every release,
and so if you really care
about your build speed,
the best thing to do is
to upgrade to the latest--
Stable, Beta, Canary, whichever
you feel most comfortable with.
Down to toolings.
There are some tools
out there that you
can start leveraging to
better understand your builds.
One that I really
like is --scan.
It's a free tool from Gradle.
It uploads some of your build
data into Gradle servers
and then provides very
comprehensive dashboards
around task durations,
plugins, dependencies,
and many, many more things.
So if you're trying to
understand what's going on with
your build-- why is it slow?--
this is a very, very
useful resource to use.
If sharing some of your
build data with Gradle
is not something you
feel comfortable doing,
here's the poor man's version
of it, which is --profile.
--profile would create
a local HTML file
that you can open
in a browser to show
some information
about your build.
It's definitely not
as rich as the --scan,
but it provides some
information and remains local.
You can combine it with --info,
which gives you information
on why a given task ran.
Another tip, which is more
of a continuous request,
is to file a bug.
We really try to test
all of our releases
on as many environments
and use cases that we can,
but there's always edge cases
and different configurations
out there.
So please file bugs when
you encounter issues.
And when you do file a bug,
please include a scan with it.
It really helps us go
deeper into the issue
and understand what's going on.
Last but not least, if
you're writing plugins,
whether it's for you, to publish
them, or even just customize
a little bit your
build file, here
is a set of tips to follow.
First, as Jerome alluded
to, configuration
is really just to set up tasks,
not really do anything else.
And as we mentioned
earlier, remember,
if you need to compute
things for up to date checks,
you can always use
provider and suppliers
to only run those
checks if your task is
part of the active graph.
For example, in
configuration, you
should not do things like
query get, read a file,
search for a connected
device, or compute anything.
Configuration is really just
a place to set up tasks,
and it's the place
to set up all tasks,
because build
doesn't really know
what paths it's going
to take in advance, so
really try to set
up all of your tasks
in the configuration step.
Regarding tasks, make sure that
each tasks declare all input
and outputs, even if
it's non-file ones,
and make sure that they're
incremental and cacheable.
If you're working
with a complex step,
try to split it
into multiple tasks.
This really helps with
the incrementally,
because some tasks could be up
to date while others do work.
And if you have multiple tasks,
they could run in parallel.
So it helps with
incrementality and parallelism.
This third best
practice sounds obvious,
but I still want to
put it out there.
Make sure your tasks don't write
into or delete any other tasks'
output.
When you write tasks, use Java
and Kotlin instead of Groovy,
and put them in a
plugin/buildSrc folder.
And last but not least, as
you've heard from Jerome,
leverage the new worker API--
we didn't talk about this, but
leverage the new worker API.
JEROME DOCHEZ: I did talk
about parallel stuff.
LEO SEI: That really
helps with parallelism.
All right.
If you didn't get clear pictures
of all of what I just said,
don't worry.
We're working on
a full write up,
covering everything
that we talked
about around speed, around
the findings that I shared,
the tooling, the best
practices, and more.
So stay tuned.
To recap, here's the take
away from this session.
First, we shared some
findings on speed
and that we're
basically a little bit
outpaced by some of the
features, the plugins, and all
the other things that are
impacting build speed,
but we're taking
this very seriously.
And so we're doubling
down our effort
on better tooling and
attribution that you heard,
as well as continuing
to improve performances.
We shared the new
features in 3.2,
and I definitely encourage
you to upgrade to 3.2,
if you haven't already.
And we mentioned some
of the things that
are working for 3.3 and beyond.
And, by the way, 3.3
beta is available,
so I encourage you to try it.
It has some of the
things that we mentioned,
like lazy tasks and others.
Last, I talked about some of
the tools that you can use--
--scan, --profile--
today to understand your build,
and shared some of the best
practice if you're writing
plugins or customizing
your build speed.
That's it for today.
I want to make a bad
joke, but, unlike build,
we finished earlier
than expected, so.
[MUSIC PLAYING]